[Music]  i'm paul reginato a biological engineer  at the mcgovern institute at mit  i make maps of cells  think of a cell as a tiny city with all  sorts of objects interacting in  organized ways the way most scientists  study cells gives us a list of the  objects within them  that helps but we need to know where  things are in addition to what things  are  that's where i come in i make maps of a  cell's dna or its genome each cell  contains six feet of dna and all this  dna has to fit into a tiny space only 10  microns wide  further it needs to be organized into  specific shapes in different cells to  function properly  we developed a technology that lets us  read the letters of the genome right  inside the cell  this allows us to create a map  by showing us how dna is organized  inside cells our mapping technology will  be useful for understanding how neurons  process information and much much more